hello everyone I am addressing a
question from Mary post at global she
asked the question you know there is an
education disparity across the world and
what can be done to really ameliorate it
and I think one thing that we need to
understand is educational opportunities
you'd be equal across the world and one
thing that I've noticed speaking here as
a journalist but having the opportunity
to speak to many CEOs and executives in
the c-suite is I realized that there's
so much potential and some of these
emerging economies that Owen Sox labels
a 10-11 Nigeria Indonesia and some of
these other places I think it's so
important to really inspire in these
youth entrepreneurism and oftentimes
what happens these entrepreneurs in the
work countries liana in these and 11
countries don't have access to capital
don't have access to I people who can
really bolster their ideas and so what
the United States really needs to do
because let's face it the United States
really is a powerhouse in terms of
Education one thing that they can do is
issue visas entrepreneurial visas to
these students one of these great
entrepreneurial ideas and these
developed and developing economies and
have them come over to the United States
so they can have access to not only the
talent but also the mentorship as well
as a capital and so I'm a huge fan of
that and another issue is that once they
get to be says let's help them get jobs
here in the United States for so that
they can actually grow their idea and
take that back to to where they're from